Okay, so listen, we're this next story. Not
something that I already suspected. I wouldn't
even be bringing it up, but as many of you
know, I have long suspected that Donald Trump,
from my completely amateur, unsophisticated
point of view, sometimes seems to be on uppers
and sometimes seems to be clearly coming down
from uppers. There are pictures now which
appear to show boxes and boxes of Sudafed
and upper, uh, at Donald Trump's desk. We're
going to get to all of the details. There
is the upper Trump I've mentioned before.
That's the one that is speaking quickly, sweating,
often sniffing a lot. And then there's the
other Trump, the slow slurring, God blush,
the United shades of America, the depressed
looking and sounding Trump. And it's all very
weird. And this goes back to that bizarre
tweet that Donald Trump sent during his 2016
campaign where he proclaimed that he loves
Hispanics while eating a taco bowl from the
Trump tower. Grill remembered this tweet and
picture happy single Demasio. The best taco
bowls are made in Trump tower grill. I love
Hispanics. And the really fascinating thing
here is not actually Trump's taco bowl, but
it's what's in the drawer just to Donald Trump's
left and behind him over his left shoulder
short, sort of, there's an open drawer, which
Twitter user, J railing points out is filled
with boxes of Sudafed. Quote. In 2016 Trump
posted a photo of himself that Gable gave
away more than he intended.
An open desk drawer revealed box after box
of Sudafed piled on top of one another and
when you look closely at that picture, you
do see what look like at least four boxes
of Sudafed. Now Jay railing makes a few other
claims in his tweet thread. I've tried to
research them and they are even more interesting.
The first one for example is that although
the photo was taken in New York, the boxes
include a type that is only sold in the U
K with a different box and distinctive ingredients
not found in the U S I went on cvs.com and
indeed that version of Sudafed is not sold
in the United States. Currently they sell
others but not that one. Same thing at Walgreens.
So it seems that at least currently this Sudafed
is not even available in the United States.
Now as we know, Trump often seems overly alert
and has notably dilated pupils to symptoms
of taking exactly this.
Now the thing is, this is not a new allegation.
No Kassler is a New York city comedian who
worked on Trump's show, the apprentice and
has said many times Trump was snorting Adderall
and eating Sudafed. Quote, Trump snorted Adderall
all through the day on apprentice. He also
ate UK Sudafed like candy, but at night and
at parties he switched to cocaine and high
end methamphetamine. That was hand delivered
by bikers. The point is he was always high.
That hasn't changed. And of course if you
go back to the video of Trump's debates with
Hillary Clinton, there was that constant sniffing
that also raised questions about Trump's drug
use. Remember this
[inaudible]
so that's difficult to listen to. I apologize,
I'm just being thorough here and again, often
extremely dilated pupils that just don't seem
to make sense for the amount of light that
is in the room where the pictures are often
taken. So am I saying to make fun of Trump?
No, he may well have a problem, but it is
to point out that upper Trump and downer Trump
have been visibly very different from the
beginning. And I can only imagine that if
someone has access to nuclear weapons and
is involved in diplomatic conversations with
world leaders at the highest level, this is
not what you want. You don't want upper and
downer version of the world leader that can
launch nuclear weapons, make or break alliances
and relationships, slap tariffs that destroy,
you know, hundreds of thousands of workers
businesses. This is not a guy that's not a
position rather where you want a guy that
has an upper version and a downer version.
I want to hear from you about this. What do
you make of this? When I've brought up the
Trump upper downer stuff in the past, I get
a substance abuse professionals who email
me and they say, David, don't use my name.
I, it would not be appropriate for my name
to be publicly attached to this, but I've
been noticing the exact same thing as you
and I think you're exactly spot on. Let me
know what you think about this. The pictures,
the sniffing, the dilated pupils, the entire
thing. I do want to hear from you about it.